donc moi qu'est ce qui vous a convaincu
de vous lancer dans cette course à la
chefferie bien c'est suite à mes
consultations comme je le dis depuis
plusieurs semaines que je faisais des
consultations travaux canada sabine et
et ça a été vraiment un appui formidable
pour tout le canada et je me suis aperçu
que j'étais capable de bâtir une
organisation solide et fiable pour la
course au leadership
c'est ce qu'on a fait est maintenant
bien on est prêt à déposer notre
candidature est aussi je travaillais
beaucoup sur la plateforme
on a développé les thèmes de la
prochaine course au leadership pour nous
donc on est prêt au point de vue des
idées j'ai toujours dit que je voulais
faire un débat d'idées avec les
canadiens avec les membres de notre
parti est la première étape pour faire
tout ça c'est déposé c'est ce que je
vais faire cette semaine à ottawa
d'ailleurs achevé à ottawa dans les
prochaines heures pour aller déposer
cette candidature la est normalement est
un candidat officiel d'ici quelques
semaines
confirmé par le parti confirmée par
élections canada
moi je crois que ça doit être quelqu'un
qui défend des valeurs concerts contes
de liberté de responsables qu'individuel
d'équité de respect respect de la
constitution canadienne respect des
payeurs de taxes c'est ce qui est plus
important
et puis si d'autres candidats qui
viennent du québec bien tant mieux moi
je vais débattre de ses idées là avec
l'ensemble des canadiens c'est le plus
important c'est qu'est ce qu'un candidat
comment candidat voit notre parti dans
les prochaines années et aussi la vision
d'un cadre d'un d'un gouvernement
conservateur parti bien moi je vais
apporter je crois un vent de fraîcheur
et surtout des idées les gens me
connaissent êtes leur liberté
responsabilité individuelle des
politiques publiques basée sur l'équité
et le respect nous allons développer ces
thèmes là durant la prochaine course au
leadership avec des discours sur
différents sujets qu'on pense à
l'immigration à la constitution à au
système de taxation
il ya plusieurs idées majeures qui vont
découler de ces de ces thèmes-là de la
campagne
le français oui absolument d'ailleurs
notre chef actuel on bosse le confirmer
le dit la plupart des gens le disent il
faut qu'un chef puisse être capable de
s'exprimer dans les deux langues
comme vous dites au québec on a fait une
belle une belle progression québec grâce
aux qualités de candidats que nous avons
je pense à monsieur deltell à québec qui
relié rallier avec lui les gens de
québec
c'est important et oui c'est primordial
que quelqu'un puisse s'exprimer en
français et en anglais aussi
d'ailleurs j'ai dit au centre manning
lorsqu'il ya une conférence des
conservateurs et des candidats
potentiels à l'époque que j'avais bien
être de débattre avec monsieur o'leary
en français c'est important et vous
pouvez compter sur moi pour pouvoir
continuer à m'exprimer dans des deux
langues et exprimé les mêmes idées dans
les deux langues